[Music]
hi guys
it's quinn the youtube algorithm
promotes content that has high
engagement
if you appreciate my videos please hit
the like button so that our youtube ai
overlord
shines its favor upon me in dan simmons
epic science fiction saga
there are several planets known to be
labyrinthine worlds
the libertine worlds were always similar
to each other
each world was earth-like the galactic
hegemony
has a method of measuring earth-like
worlds known as the soul myth scale
each of the labyrinthine worlds measured
at least a 7.9 out of 10
on the scale and they always circled a
g-type star
the labyrinthine worlds were all
tectonically dead
meaning the continents did not shift as
they did on earth
and below the surface of each of the
labyrinthine worlds
a minimum of 10 kilometers deep were
systems of elaborate tunnels
thousands of kilometers of tunnels
catacomb the entirety of each world
the tunnels of each world were exactly
30 meters square
and had perfectly smooth walls since the
hajira
mankind's great exodus from the planet
earth into space
more than eight thousand worlds had been
explored and out of those
nine worlds were found to have
labyrinths though it is mentioned
multiple times in the series that there
are nine labyrinthine worlds
only three of them are ever actually
named armaguas
svoda and hyperion many planetary arctic
historians devoted their lives to the
study of the labyrinths
the hyperion labyrinths are mentioned to
have thousands of entrances
the labyrinths of each world were also
extraordinarily old
each constructed more than 750 000 years
ago
long before humanity ever left earth and
potentially before humankind even
existed
in its current evolutionary form the
labyrinth seemed to have been
constructed by an ancient race of beings
who the people of the human hegemony
named the builders
who the builders were or the reasons for
constructing labyrinths
were completely unknown no signs of
excavation machinery
no rusting miners helmets not a single
piece of shattered plastic or
decomposing sim stick wrapper
researchers have not even identified
entrance and exit chefs
no suggestion of heavy metals or
precious ores
has been sufficient to explain such a
monumental effort
no legend or artifact of the labyrinth
builders has survived
each of the nine labrinthian worlds has
been probed many times
nothing has ever been found however the
tunnels had been created by some
technology unknown to the hegemony
it is mentioned in the first book that
it has been suggested that a fusion
tunneler
would have explained the perfect
construction of the tunnels
but such archaeological theories did not
explain where the builders
or their technology came from nor did
they explain why the builders had
expended so much effort to construct
seemingly meaningless engineering
projects
the world of hyperion itself held
several mysteries
the origin of the time tombs the
motivation of the mysterious creature
known as the strike
the legend of the bakura the fact that
hyperion was one of the nine labrinthaan
worlds seemed in comparison to some of
the other mysteries
inconsequential but the bakura are such
a small mystery
at most you're going to find a few dozen
indigenes
living in a region so cloudy and smoky
and unimportant that even the colony's
own
map sats haven't noticed them why choose
them when there are big mysteries to
study on hyperion like the labyrinths
hoyt had brightened did you know that
hyperion is one of the nine labyrinthine
worlds father
it's hard not to speculate when
presented with the many mysteries of the
hyperion cantos
a major possibility is that it is all
connected
the labyrinths the time tombs the strike
considering that time travel is in fact
possible in the hyperion cantos
it is not outrageous to consider that
the labyrinths were constructed using
future technology
by time travelers as the time tomb
seemed to have been
the involvement of the techno core seems
likely
the technocorp is the sentient
combination of artificial intelligences
that had evolved from human-made
software originating on earth
it is revealed at some point that the
techno core had sinister intentions
against humanity
i'm planning on making another video in
the future going into more detail about
the technical
and their connection to the legendary
being known as the strike
the mystery of the nine labyrinthine
worlds and the builders who constructed
them
is perhaps dan simmons's way of
reflecting the real world mysteries
of how ancient monuments were
constructed many of the specific details
about how certain ancient structures
such as the great pyramids
stonehenge and the underground city of
derenkuyu
are not known to archaeologists placing
the construction of the labyrinth
hundreds of thousands of years before
the dawn of human civilization however
adds an extra layer of mystery any
civilization capable of constructing
these enormous tunnels
on multiple worlds must have been great
and technologically advanced
so where did they go and how is it that
they left
not a single thank you guys so much for
watching make sure you like and
subscribe for more quinn's ideas